there hasn't been a lot of Lilo and
Stitch movies since the mid-2000s now
there's finally going to be a follow-up
on Disney plus with a live action film
adaptation the story of the two odd
friends is world famous and it was
really only a matter of time before the
project which was announced back in 2018
would move forward the website night
Edge media exclusively announced at the
end of last week that the actress of the
young Lilo has been cast the actress
concerned is newcomer Maya kiloa who was
involved for the first time in such a
major project one aspect stands out
immediately she Bears an uncanny
resemblance to the cartoon character a
shitstorm due to miscasting as with
other Disney projects is therefore
unlikely